Hilary Clinton today accepting full
responsibility for the election loss
except for the part when she blamed
Comey Putin WikiLeaks misogyny in the
media if you are saying he can't do his
job because of his race is that not the
definition of racism there are a few
broadcast journalists as fearless dogged
and engaged as CNN's Jake Tapper who
showed the lead airs every weekday at
4:00 p.m. the 49 year old Philadelphia
native arrived at CNN after a stint at
ABC News but his journalistic
sensibility was shaped in the late 90s
and early aughts when he wrote for
alternative media outlets such as salon
for Washington City Paper and the
pioneering satire site suck calm tapper
has just released his first novel the
Hellfire Club which is set in 1950s DC
it features cameos by historical figures
such as Jack Kennedy and Joseph McCarthy
and involves all sorts of sexual
intrigue and political corruption tapper
sat down with reason to talk about the
new book and why his alternative media
routes give him a leg up on journalists
who came up through the traditional
mainstream media Jake Tapper thanks for
talking reason it's great to see you
again
well let's talk about the Hellfire Club
which chronicles The Adventures of an
accidental and fictional congressman
named Charlie martyr in the mid-50s as
he stumbles across a conspiracy
involving massive corruption of
politicians lobbyists military
contractors and military figures what
led you to write a novel in this novel
in the first place
I thought it was fun I thought it'll be
challenging there was a there were there
are a lot of thoughts I had about
Washington DC having lived here now and
covered it for a couple decades that I
wanted to kind of express in a way that
that was more emotional than fact-based
meaning in a fictional way charlie
martyr and his wife come to Washington
as you say and and one of the things
that the the book tries to depict in in
addition to this conspiracy that they
stumble into is the compromises that
people in Washington are forced to make
and the fact that good people come here
to this town wanting to do good
Democrats Republicans independents and
little by little they make compromises
sometimes they're small like I'm I won't
criticize anybody in my party kind of
thing right but sometimes they're bigger
and next thing you know
you know they're drowning in the swamp
president Trump's not wrong about the
swamp you know the swamps real swamps
you know that I don't know that he's
fixing it but the swamps a problem
so I mean one of the things that I
really enjoyed about the book which is a
really good page-turner and particularly
early on it's it's rich in these kinds
of historical details before the the
plot kind of takes over because it is a
mystery etc and it's fun it's a I highly
recommend anybody reading it buying it
and reading it but it's rich in these
kind of historical details
irony's nuances so for instance Bobby
and Jack Kennedy have a cameo kind of
early on but then and you mention him
Chuck Joe McCarthy is a big figure in
the book and Roy Cohn his odious aide
but you you point out that Bobby Kennedy
is kind of like a good guy but that he
also he was there because he's working
for McCarthy and McCarthy is even the
godfather of one of his kids why is it
useful to remind people that there are
only feet of clay among politicians I
mean I just thought that that the fact
that the Kennedys and McCarthy were
actually close in real life was an
important part of the story and also an
important part of what I was trying to
capture in terms of the Washington swamp
and the alliances that exist the
Kennedys and McCarthy were buddies maybe
because it was the 50s and they were all
Irish and it was kind of tribal as one
member of the Kennedy family explained
to me one time when I asked why but you
know ambassador Kennedy who's also kind
of looming in the background in the book
that's Joseph Joseph or the father of
Jack and and and Robert Kennedy he
convinced McCarthy not to campaign
against John F Kennedy for Senate in
1952 that's a fact
I mean I put in this conspiracy in
secret society to try to explain in some
ways but that's true do you think that
Washington I mean you and and the book
is is reminiscent of books like Allan
Rory's advise and consent and there
there used to be this genre of a kind of
DC novel which was about how politics is
always soul-killing and and compromise
inducing but you know that genre seems
to have kind of faded is that because
politics really isn't as bad as it used
to be
well that's a really tough question well
first of all should point out that that
there are good guys in the book and the
good guys a lot of them are politicians
too so it's not as though I don't think
any politician can do good but that said
I think that it is somewhat less swampy
today in Washington because of a the
post-watergate reforms and there's more
transparency there's more aggressive
journalism there are more journalistic
outlets out there choosing one one of
the amazing things about the book is
that you know and then the title gives
away a secret society called the
Hellfire Club which is based on kind of
17th century or in seventeen to
eighteenth century sex clubs and kind of
businessman clubs in England and
elsewhere and yeah and you point that
out in pretty good detail the the press
was in the club right I mean and
certainly through the 60s and you could
argue later but but not in the way that
they used to be where the press was they
it's not just they were covering for
politicians they were right there next
to him at the whorehouse basically
totally a hundred percent I mean look we
know that the press sport covered up for
for instance John F Kennedy and his
infidelities that do mean that's just a
fact and so I think that inevitably
we're better off today one of the kind
of like throwaway scenes in the book is
Joseph Alsop is it was a famous
columnist a real one
yeah he wrote three or four times a week
with his brother and in the book it
comes out that I also did work for the
CIA while also being a columnist that's
true that's based on a Carl Bernstein
wrote a story about it I think for a
Rolling Stone there's a whole EndNote
section at the end of the book about so
people can find out what's true and
what's not true but he really did that I
mean that just boggles the mind would
you do something no never
would you admit that you were doing if
you were doing it well I wouldn't do it
but now you've caught me do it then no
matter what I mean because that that
type of shift is is pretty amazing right
well that journalists I I mean it's
interesting that in various institutions
across American life where confidence is
leaking out politicians media you know
various other places the police they're
actually more professionalized than
they've ever been I'm yeah I think
journalists have many more ethics now
than they did in the 50s or 60s
yeah I think that things are I think the
things are better without question I
will say the one differential is there's
a lot more money in the swamp now then I
think there was in the 50s now is that
because and this is the libertarian me
coming out is that because the
government controls so much more of our
lives and they you know the book in many
ways is a critique at a pretty
resounding one of the military
industrial complex yeah but it's
everything everybody can come here I
mean we're in The Hunger Games right
this is the capital district and it's
pulling in money from all over the
country right Eisenhower is a character
in the book and he says things about the
military industrial complex in in a
scene that takes place in 1954 that a
lot of which I just took from his
farewell address in 1961 and the idea
that soon will be
you know Eisenhower talks about the his
fear that soon will we will be waging
Wars based on what these companies want
us to do and not what's based on what's
best for the American people which is of
course something you guys write about
all the time well and it's a kind of
amazing that Eisenhower who's like you
know one of the great generals and one
of the great thinkers and also
increasingly understood to be a very
good president president yeah you know
we didn't really have a standing army
before World War two and 20 years later
he's worrying about a you know a
standing army and a perpetual warfare
state yeah I mean that the Pentagon
didn't exist until in the middle of
World War two it opened and the US Air
Force was just part of the army I mean
the the the military expanded
significantly and and more concerning
than that because obviously we do need
to have a military protecting US
interests is the fact that there's so
much money billions trillions of dollars
and that is in the fear of President
Eisenhower going to affect foreign
policy so that these companies can sell
things and make a lot of money and I
think that that is I think this warning
has been borne out and a great deal of
the book the premise of it is has to do
with this company
general kinetics and the power it is
wielding behind the scenes so you know
it's a it's a fun thriller but it is
based on a premise that is all too real
you know yeah I mean the book is is
casually Richard history which I
appreciate a lot it and some you know
some of it is that you seem to be in a
lot of your work you seem to be able to
look backward to say the world war two
euro or even before but you know you're
interested in drawing connections from
the past to the present none of the
stuff we're going through is
particularly new it might have some
novel twist to it
why isn't that attitude more you know
more widespread in the media I think
because it takes a certain confidence in
making the analysis because it is an
analysis and some some would even call
it an opinion you know when I was
researching this book you know the
saying the old saying history doesn't
repeat itself but it rhymes I don't know
who said it
quote investigator does I you know I
actually use that that's mine I would
love to attract it to you but you can't
read about the 50s and not hear a lot of
rhyming today whether it's about the
swamp whether it's about you know
whether if you're suspicious of the deep
state you know take a look at janitor
Hoover forget James Comey and then also
just Donald Trump McCarthyism and
trumpism are very different they stand
for very different things but the
technique of the big lie smearing and
and telling lies
you know McCarthy was doing that and at
the time the media and Democrats and
Republicans were all paralyzed not all
but most of them were paralyzed they
didn't know how to deal with this oh my
god am i biased if I call him a liar oh
my god is he gonna attack me if I calm a
liar and yet we were we see the same
mistake speak did you saw that in
spectacular relief during the Republican
primary debate yeah Trump you know I
mean he was surrounded by you know the
best that the Republican Party had to
offer an incredibly deep bench and he
was able to just dispense with them one
after another by you know defending them
away I mean part of you I think part of
any observer has to be like God that
guy's [ __ ] great at that but is it
also disturbing or is it that
politicians get
what they want you know Jeb Bush started
to cry when Donald Trump made fun of his
mother I mean he looked like he was
about to cry maybe he doesn't deserve to
be on that stage well I will tell you
this
so I'm moderated the second Republican
debate and Simi Valley at the Ronald
Reagan Library and the very first
question there were 11 people on stage
very first question Carly Fiorina I said
Governor Jindal said he wouldn't feel
comfortable with Donald Trump's hand on
the nuclear codes how do you how would
you feel
Trump at this point it was September he
was number one he'd been number one
who's center stage sucking out all the
oxygen of the room and anyway so I asked
the Fiorina thinking you know you
muscled your way on stage Carly let's do
it and she whipped it she just said you
know that's up for the voters I went to
trump he started railing about Rand
Paul's inclusion on the stage right so
then I go to completely irrelevant
I go to Jeb Bush same question he also
whiffs it yeah and I thought to myself
this guy's gonna get the nomination
Donald Trump because they don't get it
they don't understand that you you can't
wait for someone else to take him out
you have to explain why this why Bobby
Jindal from the undercard debate is
Right if you want to take him out and
they wouldn't do it and it was you know
none of them would go after him until it
was too late and by that time whether it
was Marco Rubio or Ted Cruz they just
looked desperate yeah do you think
Hillary Clinton went after him in the
right way obviously in the end it I mean
you know it's it's it's a weird election
because she did win the popular vote but
she lost the electoral vote and I think
most people whatever you want to believe
about Russia I mean she ran a terrible
campaign to lose to this guy but did she
not attack him in the right way kind of
front front and center and go after him
or what was her problem I was very
surprised that their attack on him was
all about the indecency and the Access
Hollywood tape and and the sexism not
that I don't think that's a decent
attacking it's a good attack but then
there was a whole other line of attack
that I was surprised they kind of just
like let lie which was I feel that they
strategically decided we're not going to
get these white working-class voters so
it's not even waste our time with a
hence they didn't go to rural
Pennsylvania as much as they should have
Michigan Wisconsin it's Saturday went to
Chipotle more than she went to Wisconsin
right darn well I guess that's that's
because we know she went you know we we
have the camera approach which I know
you oppose on a theoretical oh yeah you
know if it's a private business I guess
so I don't know but I you know somebody
showed after Hillary lost Hillary
Clinton lost somebody showed an image
from the 2012 campaign of Mitt Romney
was from an attack ad against Mitt
Romney in that ran in Michigan and it
was Mitt Romney with a trump plane
behind him and it was a an attack on
Mitt Romney as a phony he's gonna steal
your jobs he's a robber baron blah blah
blah that whole attack I don't think
that they didn't enough attacks like
that against Donald Trump about the fact
that at least two of the three buildings
were being Trump buildings were being
purchased about constructed with
imported steel imported Chinese steel
that he has a long history of stiffing
working-class voters I work
working-class workers for his projects I
mean there was there was I mean whatever
you think of Mitt Romney right he paid
his bills I mean he might not have been
a member of the working class but I
don't think he was I think that Donald
Trump would have been a much easier
person to attack on the working class
issues than Mitt Romney because there
was a you know you could have just
interviewed a guy literally wearing a
you know a hardhat helmet saying like
you know I put this drywall in for
Donald Trump and he stiffed me he
doesn't care about the working class but
they didn't do any of that that I saw at
least they just did the Donald Trump
says this about women Donald which is
again typically effective attack for the
women in the suburbs of Philadelphia but
I don't know about the working-class
people in the middle of State let's talk
about politicians a little bit more
politicians or the political class as
well as things institutions like the
presidency and the White House
independent of who's in them now again
massive declines in trust in confidence
yeah what is at the root of that why why
are people do you think why are people
so disgusted by Washington politics and
then what can politicians do
to change that well I think first of all
people are losing confidence in
everything right I mean they're losing
confidence in the media and politicians
and in in also in Volkswagen and Tesla
yeah I mean yeah people don't trust
anything and I think one of the reasons
is there's so much more information and
a lot of that information is negative in
terms of media in terms of other other
other information what can politicians
do - yeah - you know to regain the trust
and confidence of America I think they
can stop talking like politicians it
just drives me crazy I just I just don't
understand it why not just talk like a
real person why you know what do they
know so I mean but this is like saying
you know you get money and you can make
your own Hollywood movie and you say you
know what I'm not gonna do all those
cliches I'm not gonna do this or that
but then you end up making the same
movie over and over again is there I
mean do politicians talk like that
because maybe you and I and the media
want them to be real but people really
don't that might be right I mean
ultimately maybe what you and I are
yearning for doesn't play and actually
would hurt them I mean there is an
argument to make that transparency while
important actually hurts the person
being transparent I know for instance
like every time I give a speech for
money I give all the money to charity
and I disclose it on my tumblr account
and I tweet about it and they give a
link and say I just talked to this group
this is what I talked about this is who
they are this is where all the money is
going for blah blah blah and I know that
there are people who saying why are you
even doing that all you're doing is
exposing yourself to criticism nobody
else in media does that and so many
people give speeches for money and that
is it's probably true that it would be
no better for I mean I'm that I'm
subjecting myself to more criticism that
way you know Justin Amash the
libertarian leaning Republican Congress
congressman from Michigan he lists and
explains every vote that he takes on his
Facebook page is that a good model for
politician rate but it's but it's
probably more downside than upside right
I mean that's just the bottom line is
that when it comes to this transparency
business and I know this is somebody who
tries to be
of transparence as much as transparent
as I can be without boring people to
death
madad that I'm side when I sin etre Roy
Blount came on my show and Sunday on my
Sunday show and I asked them basically
doesn't it bother you the Donald Trump
lies so much he didn't reject the
premise of the question he's in he said
it would probably bother me more you
know if we weren't getting so much
accomplished so he kind of admitted it
by the same token he also wouldn't like
give a bite in which he said like well I
wish you wouldn't lie so much yeah you
know it's probably it'd probably be
better for himself if so if he told the
truth who are the politicians that you'd
like talk or not that you like talking
to but you think our Paragons of
transparency or trust or just realness
wow that's such a tough question I mean
name names
I mean but like they all all of them to
a degree show a little leg though of the
of the ones I'm talking about first of
all there are the ones that like never
admit anything you like you have leader
Pelosi on and you say this congressman
just told her I'm seen an offensive joke
about Kelly and Conway what's your
response and and Nancy Pelosi is like I
don't know anything and what about
cocaine Mitch does he he's so busy doing
bumps that like you can't even get him
to do an interview so mitch mcconnell's
eight-balls aside the the I mean they're
you know Rand Paul is somewhat open yeah
somewhat candid you know but yeah so his
cory booker so is Lizabeth warren so i
mean all of them show a little egg they
talked a little bit about you know
honest answers but to a degree they all
kind of stick to their talking points
and avoid criticizing their own party so
recently i was listening to an interview
you did with Kellyanne Conway who is an
interesting character and is kind of a
professional liar I mean forget Sarah
Sanders like she will you know and she's
great at it I mean I I really kind of
admire it she's like oh thank you with
my era she's like no I do I mean in
terms of her performance it's like
artificial intelligence like I don't
think somebody nobody you know
in in science fiction movies you can
always get a computer to explode if you
get it to contradict itself she's never
going to explode right what is it like
dealing with people who you know are
just gonna [ __ ] you when you have
them on your show now I would say that
what she did on Sunday was less lying
and more deflecting I would I would say
I would argue that as opposed and
already I'm saying they win because
you've already created this incredible
glossary of terms like well that's not a
lie it's a deflection yeah it's not a
deflection you know it's a repost or you
know it's Krav Maga it's like the
Israeli martial art so I I mean yeah no
I agree with you look I mean to a to a
large extent any of any time that you
are now talking about how they dealt
with your questions about a serious
issue dealing with the president they've
won or you know Stephen Miller comes on
my show he came on my show started
attacking me and then if an interviewer
asks me how I feel about that and what I
was going through my head like I'm now
not talking about President Trump
tweeting that he's a very stable genius
or whatever or with Kellyanne Conway I
was pressing her on a few things one of
them was the president tells lots of
lies and her basic argument was again
didn't disagree with the premise but
basically said but like but you don't
cover all the times he tells the truth
you know that was basically which is by
the way I wrote I wrote an entire said I
feel so bad for her kids I'd be like she
is you know just great I wrote an entire
piece for McSweeney's in the middle of
this crazy last year that was basically
how come we're not talking about all the
presidents that John Wilkes Booth didn't
kill right which is but which is which
is the counter-argument to all of this
yeah and then you know I said well you
know the president goes on Twitter and
says there are three hostages in North
Korea and President Obama Gooden
couldn't get them out but we're gonna
get him out stay tuned whatever
something like that and I said killing
in two of those hostages were taken
during the Trump presidency so well
you're focused on the tweet we're
focused on getting out the hostages so I
mean again
does this help explain
long-term declines in cable news view it
no because I mean I know I'm you know I
[ __ ] do this for a living and I can't
stand listening to that kind of talk
because it's I got better things to do
actually cable news Ewing is up from
like two years ago right so but that's
why I said the long-term decline I think
the long-term decline is because it's
not just cable news viewing it's a
long-term decline in everything because
there are 7000 channels I mean the
network's if I would be remiss if I
didn't mention that reason TV is one of
them and it's an fantastic it's getting
better and better and and I appreciate
there are no ads because that would be
such a sell enough so the network news
divisions right they have seen I think
the most precipitate precipitous
drop-off in viewership they're still
strong and everything like that but
because there are so many channels and
now if you are a political junkie you
don't have to wait till 6:30 to get the
news you can turn on CNN or any of our
competitors but now you see you've
deflected the question no I'm saying I'm
not lucky knowledge iing the question
like as a larger trend so what I'm
saying everyone is facing this because
there are so many channels I you know
one of the reasons that I admire your
work is that you're very forthright
about this kind of stuff and but what
can other media people do or what can
your colleagues at CNN as well as at
MSNBC and Fox News what can they do to
squeeze more reality out of the people
that they're bringing on or the way that
they present the news well I mean I'm
not here to give advice to other people
but I'll just say like I think that the
more I think that when you are in that
chair or standing there with a
microphone you are not there for
yourself you're there for the people at
home and you should be answering the
questions and conducting yourself in a
way trying to think about like what they
would want you to do well you didn't
really answer that question or you know
I'd really isn't it true that something
you know that we're there to challenge
that and at a time when there is just
this is this waterfall cascading over us
of [ __ ] it's important for us to
like you know put up an umbrella try to
provide a safe space for viewers to know
we're trying to not have any [ __ ]
here and when it comes on the show we
will call
out in a respectful way and that's the
most we can do well and in the wake of
the White House Correspondents Dinner
you you emerge as a critic of the way
that White House Correspondents Dinner
is done or you know in the most recent
kind of comedy presentation by Michelle
wolf you talked a lot about civility how
what is civility and is it just another
weasel word for not asking the tough
question no it's not I think tough
questions are very important I thought
that for my whole career and and maybe
there are times that I could they're
only times I always times I could look
back and think I could have done that
better I could have done that better but
I mean I think if anything I was known
for challenging the Obama administration
and now I'm known for the same thing
with Trump I have not actually been
critical of Michelle wolf what oh yeah
no I mean she's a commit she did she
showed up and did exactly did what
people hiring with her yeah no I you
know I could quibble with a joke or two
and this and that but my main point is
if we're gonna have a conversation about
decency and and and people being
respectful of one another which is not
to say we shouldn't disagree with them a
call out when they're lying but but not
insulting each other in a pure aisle or
or mean way if we're gonna have that
conversation and the Trump people now
all of a sudden want to have this
conversation because of Michelle wolf
great we've got a backlog and it starts
with President Trump suggesting that
Mexicans are rapists and like and then
it continues to him saying the giant
didn't say that some of them he guesses
are good people so you know he's he's a
very nuanced that's nice it's a great
analysis of 12 million people or saying
that John McCain isn't a war hero
because he was captured or saying you
know I know on and on making fun of a
reporter who has a disability etcetera
like let's have that conversation and no
I don't think it means don't ask tough
questions or that reporters and
politicians shouldn't go at it I just
mean you don't say politician number a
you're fat and ugly and then the
politician writes back well you're a
weasel and you're a loser that's not
what I'm talking about that's that's
uncivil but to say aren't you not
telling the truth aren't you lying to
the American people about X no I am
telling the truth here's why and that
question is biased that's fine I'm not a
problem with that do you think that that
you know the media
the way that it treats its own and you
know in the wake of the White House
Correspondents Dinner there were a
number of high-profile people like you
know Mika Brzezinski say or
Andrea Mitchell other people who were
like oh you know what the Michelle wolf
was terrible and we you know that this
was an attack on civility and on the
press that's kind of bad and then the
way that the press police is its own I
mean people like Joy Reed or Brian
Williams and I guess they're both at NBC
or MSNBC but like they get off easy it
seems when they've committed real crimes
against accurate reporting is that part
of the the crisis and confidence in the
media yeah absolutely
yeah it doesn't really do me any good to
criticize competitors right because then
people just think I'm taking a shot at a
competitor and MSNBC is a competitor but
I will say this if we don't help hold
ourselves to a standard of truth-telling
mm-hmm of owning up to mistakes then we
lose credibility and every time with
Kevin Williamson the
conservative writer from National Review
who was hired wrote one article for the
Atlantic and they said they wanted more
ideological diversity and then they
canned him and it's not you know it's
their right to do whatever they want any
of these companies can kind of do
whatever they want but it does seem to
eat away at this pretense that were a
legitimate media were not in the tank
for one or the other group but then were
you know we're always gonna protect our
own and get rid of people we disagree
with yeah I mean I that's not how I view
my job like you know we we have you know
David Urban who is a trump supporter he
ran the Trump campaign and our beloved
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania comes on my
show quite a bit he I find him to be an
artful defender of President Trump while
at the same time he's not going to
pretend it's okay to make fun of people
with disabilities and it's important
where he's not going to deny that Trump
did it for exactly even yeah which is
even worse so I think it's important to
do that and it's one of the reasons why
whenever journalism students ask me what
they should be doing and I say if you're
on social media you should be funneling
a ton of people that you don't
necessarily agree with just to get their
perspectives I always mentioned you I
always
I always mention Jonah Goldberg and
people on the right I always mention
Josh Marshall and people on the left I
think it's important to have as diverse
a feed as possible I'm not even
mentioning women which is a problem so I
get women on the left and right as well
and getting as many people of color
people from different countries etc
having as much ideological diversity as
possible so that you're getting those
inputs and having that influence how you
cover stories and having people like
that on your panels you I mean at CNN
you see yourself at you know and it's
it's a it's it's a epithet now but
you're part of the mainstream media it's
different than perspective journalism or
point of view journalism like reason you
know we're a libertarian magazine the
nation is but even but even the reason
you guys disagree oh yeah yeah no no and
and we have a code of honesty and we try
we always try to show you know not
always successfully but we try to show
our math so that people can check yeah
you know we they know our premises but
here's our math and does it add up so
people can evaluate it but you see
yourself as in a different space in the
media landscape and how does that affect
kind of questions of fairness and
objectivity because sometimes people
conflate these but you seem to have a
different understanding you can be fair
but that doesn't mean you're gonna be
objective
well objectivity is such a it's an
objectivity as a goal it's not you can
never be
you can never arrive at objectivity you
never it's an aspiration we all have our
biases some of them we own I love the
Philadelphia Eagles and I think the
United States in general is a force for
good not always but it aspires to be
those are those are biases that are
built into I don't know which one is
more objectionable but we'll let that
pass anyway so but then but then there
are there are so it's a goal and knowing
that I am you know I have the biases
that I have from my dad's a pediatrician
my mom's a nurse that means I look at
the medical debates inevitably from
their points of view it's just I was
raised as a kid of a doctor and a nurse
knowing that you have those biases is is
I think important and going going into
work as a journalist
one of the things because I started in
journalism full-time at Washington City
Paper and then at salon.com which was
very different then than it is now one
of the things I try to in view and my
coverage is that I'm willing to listen
to perspectives that I think a lot of
mainstream media at least used to kind
of just shunt aside the idea for
instance that I think it is conventional
wisdom in the United States no matter
what the US military can solve the
problem just send them and they'll solve
the problem and of course not a lot of
thought to what comes after the problem
is solved or even if they can solve the
problem but I do think there is a
conventional wisdom
I don't think president Trump if in fact
he is ultimately ever going to really
challenge that and I haven't seen any
evidence that he actually is going to
he's talked about it but ultimately he's
still kind of doing the conventional
wisdom when it comes to sending men and
women abroad I think that's a good thing
to shake up that thinking the same thing
with the trade deal same thing with
immigration everything so do you have a
politics probably I definitely even if I
were not a journalist even if I were a
screenwriter or a novelist or whatever
full-time I would not be a member of a
party I'm not now and I haven't been for
years and I there isn't a party what
party did you belong to I was a Democrat
a long time ago do you vote not for
offices that I cover but yes so like I
call vote for mayor of over city council
but I don't vote for president yeah yeah
the job is much easier given that we're
completely disenfranchised you can
Washington DC we don't have senators or
representatives truly so but I've been I
don't feel at home in a party do I have
a politics I mean I do think that I
think that a certain degree of
compassion is important but I don't know
that big government is always that's
another I think conventional wisdom kind
of way of looking at problems in
Washington whether it's bush or Obama or
frankly trunk which is more government
better and here we have a problem
more government instead of taking the
government we have now and reorganizing
it changing it so as to focus on the new
problems of 2018
I see that too that's I think something
that I've learned from reading a lot of
reason and just like having that
challenge okay let's go back to the
alternative media routes that you have
because this is fascinating in
Washington City Paper Salon in the 90s
where you were at in early 2000 and suck
calm suck calm the pioneering satire
site that we both wrote for although we
didn't know each other now what was your
name was your not that I was mr. myth
Mixel mr. Musil quick that was James
Bond James Bond yeah and I heard what I
tried to imbue in the nineties yeah so
imbue and also inhale yes that's the
whole point the you know one of the
things about the alternative media that
is kind of interesting and and you know
now it's the alternative media it is the
media because as you were saying things
of fractures or augmented and I think
ultimately good ways what are some of
the essential characteristics of that
you you seem to be more engaged not just
with the people that you're interviewing
but on your Twitter feed for instance
you you don't just trash talk big-name
people but you engage individuals you
know who may have a couple dozen
followers I try not to punch down but I
do engage with people I probably do less
of it now than I did before because
because of I don't want to punch down
and like sometimes even just responding
to somebody brings them attention
negative attention there maybe isn't
fair even if they're being even if
they're starting out being rude I think
that one of the things did my first
editor for my first full-time job in
journalism was David Carr the late
legendary
media writer for New York the New York
Times he went who started at the city
paper yeah he started Minnesota to City
Pages I'm sorry but he was the editor
and one of the things that he I was a
crime and police reporter for City paper
and he was always on my case for being
for not being sufficiently skeptical
with police he thought I was too Pro
police he never came out and said it but
I knew that he thought that and that was
good that that back-and-forth that I had
with him and while I think it's
important to support police when they
need help and they're doing the right
thing I also because of David Carr
recognized that there are
times that the police need to be
questioned and that's an important part
of my job the same thing with
decision-makers in the military less so
individual soldiers on the ground but I
think champ being willing to challenge
American institutions while also being
respectful of the people who are you
know the beat cop or the the military
trip I mean you've written a book about
soldiers yeah in overseas and it's you
can it's easy to make a distinction
really between the people who who call
the shots and the people who followed
the orders but also holding the people
who follow the order it's accountable
when they do horrible things yeah
absolutely I'm Logan of course I mean if
they do horrible things that's yeah
that's a war crime but I mean
theoretically but but it's important I
mean I think there's too much reverence
for the people who make the decisions
and maybe not enough respect for the
people who are actually carrying out the
orders and that III think that mindset
is one that comes from the alternative
media what about the distinction or
maybe the distinction isn't the right
word they made the distance between kind
of the expert and the audience so you
know people go back and we both know the
work of Joseph Campbell just W camp we
love America critics said he always he
always talks about you know when people
say oh Cronkite was the most trusted man
in America it turns out that the only
person who really believed that was
Walter Cronkite who kind of made it up
and that you know there's no evidence
that LBJ ever saw Walter Cronkite you
know say we've lost Vietnam and that's
why he decided not to run or anything
but you know there in the golden age or
the golden narrative there's Walter
Cronkite and he is up on Olympus yeah
delivering the news the audience is down
here there doesn't need to be any
interaction it seems the alternative
meteor social meter the Internet the
decentralization of knowledge and power
and information that happened in the 90s
and continues it's a lot about you know
you are not as far away from your
audience as you know even Wolf Blitzer
was ten years ago or Bernard Shaw the
early you know Lions of sea
and is that true yeah and there's look
the old model the Huntley and Brinkley
and the Walter Cronkite and the John
Chancellor that's gone there aren't
three networks anymore and there are
dozens and there aren't there's no one
person who commands the kind of power
and respect that Walter Cronkite and
Edward are Mauro and the others once did
just because there are so many different
outlets and so many different people and
and the audiences are so much smaller I
think it is important for I mean I don't
I don't have a problem with that I mean
that and and even if I did you it's
there that's the reality who cares about
a problem of it so it is important for I
think for us to try to be transparent as
much as possible for us to explain
decisions for us to do interviews with
people who challenge the media I read
all the media criticism whether it's
from Media Matters or from News Buster's
some of it I agree with some of it I
disagree with but I read it all I read
reason all the time and and look there I
mean that is word we're just in a
different world and just one thing just
a quick advertisement for the book
because you bring up W Joseph Campbell
right who as you and I talked about just
a minute ago is the ultimate buzzkill
the ultimate party pooper you want to
talk about some great yeah yeah I mean
he did a great thing about how were some
wells radio broadcast War of the Worlds
like nobody gave a [ __ ] you know that's
all Orson Welles created a great myth
around that people were like freaking
out shooting a you know as monsters or
do on Maple Street and they're shooting
each other no it didn't happen so I read
him all the time it it's almost like a
you hate Turkey it's a hate read yes
like oh you're gonna blow up another
myth that I love well this is what about
Joe Kennedy you know Joe Kennedy senior
wasn't a bootlegger and he wasn't really
a Nazi these are things that I know
because I just like he was a peon
appeaser though yeah he was well he was
worried you know he did it was a chimera
sir yeah no no it's on the wrong side I
get I agree at all I'm saying is like we
have to give up our cherished dreams
even you know that are too good to do so
he just just to give him credit there's
a scene in the book where Charlie no Joe
as you mentioned looms large in the book
he's a character in the book Charlie
interacts with him etc and there's a
scene in the book where Charlie goes
back to his his his parents house and
his dad's there Winston and he's
watching Moreau eviscerate McCarthy just
destroy him and they have a conversation
about McCarthy but one of the things
that occurs to charlie is you know
Edward I murder where you been
yeah you know this is spring 1954
senator Margaret chase Smith took on
McCarthy four years before and other
journalists have been taking on McCarthy
for years whether Jack Anderson or or
others really drew drew Pierson even who
I think got into a physical fight with
with McCarthy and there wasn't so much
of a fight McCrory punched him and he
fell and even mentions how the
cartoonist Walt Kelly who did Pogo had
even taken on McCarthy a year before so
as much as I personally revere Edward
are Murrow I learned from Campbell that
Murrow was a little late to the party
and I and I had Charlie reflect that so
- two quick final questions first you
know you mentioned David Brinkley and I
grew up watching news in the 80s and
this week with David Brinkley was a
highlight because Brinkley was funny and
rye and everything any and he hated
[ __ ]
he hated but then I learned that he was
actually personal friends with a ton of
the people that he covered and they
would all go vacationing together really
Carolina and and I felt let down by that
that is that is just yeah so are you
will you along with you know posting you
know how much money you made at a speech
and where it went to when you vacation
with cocaine Mitch where you go out to
how are you really going to Bogota the
spray so you will you will publish that
- I go on vacation with my brother and
his family and with family friends but
you know maybe I mean I I promised that
if I ever go on vacation with a
politician I will disclose it on my
tumblr account but I mean I don't think
they want to go on vacation with me I'll
tell you when Barack Obama left the
White House he he didn't keep in touch
yeah he didn't keep in touch but yes I
mean be that that is it is disappointing
I think Ben Bradley has in retrospect
talked talked about how he that he was
too close to President Kennedy clearly
yeah now I mean
that was idea so it's it's I mean it's
an interesting thing and this is what I
also I think part of in this broad sense
this alternative media world is that
there is a force transparency what you
know in it I mean it's forced on you so
you might as well get ahead of it in a
way and I think that about politicians
the baby is not to be at the colosseo I
mean that's you know for instance I am a
huge Eagles fans as I've already
mentioned an Arabic country that shall
not be named invited me to fly to the
game on their private jet attend the
Superbowl and fly back so I wouldn't
have to spend a night in Minnesota which
by the way is a lovely state no problem
with it I mean like and and and I've
talked to my wife about it because of
course I was never going to accept this
but the fact that they were offering it
this this Arab country meant that there
were people accepting it and it was just
crazy to me I'm sure they gave the seat
to Charlie Rose or somebody right or
maybe Mika Brzezinski Charlie Rose has
time on James I think it's fair to say
well it you know at least it's only time
on his hands these days right final
question and in a very minor but very
real way you owe your journalism to
jacob solemn a long time reason senior
editor absolutely Jane Jacobs solemn and
I've said this on Twitter before Jake I
was in we went to the same small Jewish
day school six through twelve in the
suburbs of Philadelphia I was in seventh
grade it's a small school so as a 7th
grader I was able to be the or I'm sorry
as an eighth grader as an eighth grader
I was able to be the art editor of the
school newspaper because nobody nine ten
eleven twelve wanted the job because
they were much cooler than I was I
suppose so I was the auditor and Jacob
solemn was one of the editors and he had
recruited me first of all to do cartoons
for the Akiba gram which it was just
what it was called I think it's now it's
called the Cougar Chronicle and and then
he encouraged me to try to be editor the
next year so the next year when the
Akiba gram had its first meeting
and I was the only one who showed up
except I brought my friends from ninth
grade then we took over the paper
because even when you have a school of
300 people and each class is like 50 you
know it's very possible that other
grades just won't even know or care so
yeah so he got me involved I became
editor-in-chief of the school paper in
ninth grade and you know so kudos to
Jacob selim who's who's uh who who I
still read all the time and he was he
probably if you I mean looking back on
if you imagine what he was like in high
school that's exactly what was like in
high school he wore a tie to school he
had a briefcase
Jacob Saul had a brief this is at least
in my memory he had a briefcase he I
think he's but he's unbuttoned a couple
buttons and he's alright yeah I think
and he he's more laid back now after 20
years of telecommuting from his house
the only marital a legalization of
marijuana advocate who has never smoked
marijuana Oh trust me I think he's
crossed that line oh he had to go
undercover to really get to the store
good friend he may well have gotten too
close for journalism at least for
journalism but but to think that he's
kind of like to marijuana what Al Pacino
was to rough trade in cruisin maybe went
a little too deep little tried a little
too Stanislavski so a little method
acting there I will just say this also
he should know that you know I think
it's important to know what you were
like as a kid and when he was in 11th
grade 12th grade and I was in seventh
grade eighth grade he was nice he was
nice and you don't have to be nice to a
seventh grader when you're in 12th grade
and but he was so that's that's how
something good about in my face
certainly well we'll leave it there
we've been talking with Jake Tapper of
CNN and the author of the new
best-selling novel the Hellfire Club
Jake thank you thank you so much Nick
for a reason I'm Nick Gillespie
you
[Music]